were so fool podcast with Felipe Esparza
and Rodrigo Taurus the rod van the art
tour is done the tourist ride the Tori
rod della Torre is my name he went
Hollywood he went Hollywood yeah what's
up everybody man we just we just got
back from San Jose man we were there for
two nights and let me tell you man I was
tired
hey I see I didn't know you were tired
because I was tired but I wasn't trying
to let nobody see that [ __ ] dawg another
48 hours dog two days I know you're
tired dude when um your hair just starts
drying up now you're here to have the
well drying double retired rope
I'll comb it anymore I know you don't
care no more we had our marching Rizzo
Johnny Rock yard super happy I know yeah
Bert Rizzo and Lou Ferrigno dog didn't
want to Ambro hell nah took it what two
days to drive home yeah man yeah it was
[ __ ] badass oh dude yeah yeah you had
the curl from Orlando it was all happy
oh hell yeah so we're like for sold-out
shows yeah dude [ __ ] crazy we have
more people than we ever had there huh
yeah I was [ __ ] packed it I wasn't
about sweating up there oh do you know
they fell hard a little bit huh a little
harder this time
first I put a little fat your hair's
gonna be going everywhere stop playing
with that monitor I swear we gotta we're
starving
love truth I got to really go give
sandwiches and um leave yeah okay cuz
you got through the night before though
what tell her bro you want to go see the
play
oh yeah all the power rod Regas play
rich how to pitch a Latino sitcom well
they would never make it on the air I
thought it was great I thought it was
fantastic
I thought it was all it could be it was
good dude I just you know rolled up in
there and from beginning to end waited
well James almost there right think I'm
a prize or something yeah he showed up
at the he he actually uh they gave him
an award before it started and then you
know he took pictures after all so
Eastside morale
Bob [ __ ] from La Bamba was their hero
Richie give me little Richie at the end
two pictures and he was cool they were
all cool dude but uh who stole the show
bro oh my god Mike Gomez let me tell you
dawg I did everybody that there's
[ __ ] great and talented to the
[ __ ] to the tee but dude Mike Gomez
dog leads leads from The Big Lebowski
dude is amazing on stage dawg his
presence dog dude great voice everything
and then I especially when he did that
Vietnam veteran part when he went to go
pick up his brother in the play on the
fourth part did it I killed it I mean he
killed it throughout the play I mean
Paul Rodriguez killed it to all the
actors on there dude the whole the
entire cast dude but it was informative
as well as as it was good dude and then
you know he had a bunch of jokes in
there too and he gave props to
everything from like Cesar Romero on the
way up to George Lopez dude
how many hang around showed up oh dude
the listening of the Latino community
Latino Hollywood was in the house I feel
like besides I'm no Beast when I'm Paul
Rodriguez playing out there I feel like
all these people support horrible place
oh they're never as good as this dude
ever um and then ever I like reach the
height of it and just like uh I guess
well you wanted the content did the
material Dawg you didn't mean they're
always in a bunch of whack ass Latino
play so he's like in your face to the
man huh oh yeah it's like dude this one
was dude it was sweet subtle it had
jokes on both ends and not just on his
in on the casting uh one cool thing was
that one actor played three characters
dog that was Chris Wood that little the
little short when they played the exec
or the camera cameraman any please
submission him Robert I've seen him
before I've seen him and stuff before
good yeah yeah that full head of hair
dude who's badass it was great dude it
was bad it was bad ass but uh yeah dude
all the schmoozers you just see that was
the best part about the smooth like it's
like you saw some users on the plane
then you see the room in real life after
oh my god it was just almost I know
whatever jeez almost did because I
didn't show one when she showed up he
gave an award and I feel left on the
back row they hit even hit him go
outside man
he said that he disappear God he was God
like a roach I didn't know why did he
leave I want to talk to you give ideas
that's why he left if you don't want to
hear my script you don't wanna hear my
ideas
dude images almost had that face like
it's ten to go is it how many man how
many actors you saw that bin on one
thing there are there was a lot of them
dude that was probably about 25 to 30
then you've seen once didn't mean what's
doing the game huh still in the game
still trying to make it happen like I
understand like we should have that guy
from blood in blood out over here which
one Montana
oh no no no matter his name is oh my god
dude I'm drawing a blank right here his
last name Montana's already a movie in
the movie what is his name dude because
there's Santana's every James almost Oh
Montana Montana I don't know you a big
big shot caller yeah yeah a meadow
meadow meadow meadow but there was a
name for him that for the stop books
yeah cuz you you met him one time when
we were with the hot cheetos dude in the
suite right at the Laker game he should
take blood in blood out proud bro well I
think you know I know he's searching for
another thing to take him to you know
like I guess not you have the Latino
connotation or the like the you know
like a gang thing or whatever it is even
though that movie is a [ __ ] enormous
classic because I know you have some
questions about it and he was like yeah
but I'm actually working on a theater
thing right now yeah but nobody brought
out yeah you weren't about to enjoy I
wish you got Sean Sean was one day oh
dude he's available dude I told you the
fricker did that i sat on that one thing
and he's all in all the actors and all
the crew we're only asking them
questions about blood and blood out
my dude that's an enormous movie dude I
bet you everything he wanted they gave
it to him
oh dude so I've been promoting his HBO
special on September 30 all week we do
this I did like five hours of non-stop
press really today or yesterday yeah man
like from 8:00 in the morning to 12 I
entered I did like I need review every
15 minutes
really so like for an hour
so I did like [ __ ] 20 interviews to get
away and then I'm gonna go do another
one in person the two in person I'll do
it any of you like tails bro like I will
talk to a person for like four minutes
and then another person will show up and
then another person will show up and
then another person so I like eight
almost like ten five-minute interviews
all at once huh dude that's a great deal
because the actor's name is Henrique
Castillo dog yeah from blood and blood
out dude trying to get his name upcoming
shows ladies and gentlemen February
September 21st through 24th that's this
week I'm gonna be at the Houston Texas
at the Houston improv will be donating
half of the proceeds to a couple of
charities Houston Food Bank and friends
for life animal shelter so this is a
good cause
and I don't want to spoil it but what's
up anyway so yeah maybe fast maybe
they're a little box
so um September 30 my HBO special
premieres at 10 p.m.
type 7 p.m. on west coast also streaming
on HBO go and HBO now the next day also
it's very important this is exclusive
what's a full podcast news okay if
you're listening to this after this date
see you listen to this a month later
taste does not apply to you okay if
you're listening to this three weeks
later this may not apply to you okay
this is got nothing to do with you but
if you're listening to it now before
September 30 before September 30th okay
we're having a viewing party for my
special that's right a viewing party
with tacos vegan tacos
beer wine chill rose every deserts the
works the works and we have a contest
where you can enter to win ticket to
come watch it with us on September 30
when it premieres that's right man
it's time to give back to the people who
laugh at my jokes and and my one-hour
special translate days premieres on
Saturday September 30 on HBO we're
having a viewing party at all things
comedy studios in our lane do you want
to come watch it with us do you for a
chance to win tickets for you and a
plus-one text Felipe two four four two
two two text Felipe two four four two
two two FPL IPE
two four four two two two two so Felipe
four four four two two two so that's the
way to win tickets to the viewing party
that we're gonna have and I heard it's
gonna be an amazing bro we gotta love a
dancer
we got like a bonanza now we got we got
our beat we're gonna use somebody else
and we're gonna have a lot of nice
desserts hell yeah do you know my memory
prizes but and we're gonna have it's
gonna be a red carpet event roll bring
your gowns ladies it'll be a red carpet
your bed we might have press there or or
pressure whatever so it's gonna happen
bro [ __ ] yeah congratulations that you
don't thank you man we're it's very hard
that you could bring a lady bro free
tacos
like a cheap date hall I excited it in
now it'll be badass yeah man so
everybody's gonna know man and they're
gonna be like what can angle because
it's a trip cuz people been hitting me
up so have you seen the whole special
I'm on listen
I'm just like you I've only seen the
trailer and I'm not lying dude so the
trailer was [ __ ] kick-ass dude yeah
man so shot I made out comedian today oh
and I've heard of him I never know him
shout out to this whole comedian Pat
Gallegos you know him I've heard the
name young coming yeah he's a friend of
mine on Facebook he were making me laugh
on the studio brothel cuz I heard cuz
I'm I didn't know he was at first we
couldn't introduce cuz he like give me a
hug and big fan whatever they were
talking and that food goes yeah man
started off let me stand up yeah man I
just do show us a bathroom but I left
them with the devil let them see you
later doc yeah man he put the leftover
crew you heard of him right yeah yeah
yeah he's on a radio station called -
radio all right on do that so that's
good man you got yourself a little job
and you get to do stand-up comedy and
that's one of the best things about
stand-up comedy when you have a job and
you could do stand-up comedy
hell yeah especially a radio at least
you're still entertainment business
that's what's up but post you know
flyers that they're gonna make a movie
you night energy every business if
you're not performing or any kind of any
part of the industry of you if you're
cleaning
how have you clean the floor at Warner
Brothers in einem you the business we're
working on a trailer we're working right
now we didn't look for funding hopefully
I'm will get to me he is almost after
this play will corner him in Castillo
Doug his name's Montana Montana blow
your blood out yeah yeah I know where
they state Montana yeah I don't know we
all kind of like almost nailed it but
yeah that's his name that's a character
name in blood blood oh yeah so I have
more upcoming show leather than John oh
man can i plug one show real quick
yeah plug in Bray Improv Tuesday of
September 26 will be there so to say
that's not a yeah man show yeah yeah
little
Rodrigo tours in the homies all right or
my facility [ __ ] a
next victim Martin Rizzo in a johnie's
rookie all right October 6 and 7
Nashville Tennessee
I'm coming to Zanies October 8
Huntsville Alabama at stand up live
October 12th through the 14th Edmonton
Alberta Canada at the comic strip yeah
bro I'm trying to take care of a problem
but you could do the passport right yeah
dude I'm ready you and I gonna roll on
that's what's up fool I'm down dude
I'm trying to get off sooner I get out
of Murray but I'm gonna pay for you
don't take it yeah pay for it hey got a
saw the watch yeah my so bring your yeah
man shows up
also October 20th San Diego at
Humphrey's by the bay October 21st Reno
Nevada at Silver Legacy casino October
26 Phoenix Arizona a stand-up live that
that's not a regular stand-up show okay
that's not a regular tandem show that's
a podcast show this is for all the odd
things comedy podcast vegetable the
ardennes Comedy Festival oh lambreaux
Earth quiz called terremoto terremoto
are you just you just struck Mexico City
what's up earthquake all right my least
I didn't go get you all right
all right terremoto yes we got them for
another real name wanna fight October
21st we don't know better silver legacy
and also man this is the artiste comedy
podcasts festival I'm doing a live worth
of food podcast and I'll be doing a
short set on one of the stand-up shows
they'll be putting together that night
check out Philippe world.com slash tour
for all the show dates and the rest of
the year on September 26 September 26 at
the brain Prague
DME for any uh there's gonna be a promo
code that we can get in for like five
bucks and yeah man [ __ ] up please
come out and support at the brave improv
thank you so much September 26 people
don't understand how much of a good deal
is to pay to actually pay for a comedy
show five bucks five bucks thing about
people walk five dollars you get to sit
there and laugh and then drink you got
two minutes to dream for the rest o
understand people just go to a like
person with man I cannot see myself
walking in to a free show and expect
that to be good dude in your life who
anything new it was free dude has a bit
like kick-ass I mean hell no I went in
line it was hot no food bad suck they
didn't give me a free t-shirt I know man
everything that had ever been - that was
actually free and always been bad it's
been a bad memory - there have been a
good memory of Eddie and I never free
yeah man that's what's up you gotta pay
a little bit dawg
yeah what happened where they give away
toy but we were in labor for hours look
at toy drive bag yeah man
toy cars are coming brother you know
what that's got me that's the comedy
fundraiser scam show and it's funny you
mention that because a couple weeks back
I was with the homies you didn't mean
I'm the bigger crowd of like how you
hang around with small people again you
know get where he came from maybe
they're all saying like one of the
biggest comedy scammers ever before they
used to donate to a cause now they he
wants cash in the envelopes dawg [ __ ]
[ __ ] bringing toys cash in envelopes bro
I heard it you know how the fundraisers
these comedy shows yeah Pat Gallegos
told me they were doing fundraisers
right for comedians right I think shout
out to Robert Morales and anyway so um
he said that was his name is doing a
comedy show fundraiser at the person's
house damn you know in a backyard show
so they scratch the venue fee don't
wanna pay read back the most Bureau
he's gotta make a living huh oh well
that's what it is dude but it's funny
cuz one of those dudes that's like the
promoter or comedian in like you know
puts on these events still lives at home
with mom right yeah what this both his
parents you know me but nice big happy
family like that most like I mean this
is how if you're your comic out there
you know you listen to a podcast and
you're doing open mic and you're doing
these shows I would say right now man if
you do open mic if you live in a
comedian I want to be a comedian okay
and you live south if you live east of
the 101 north just say you live past
Boyle Heights
II live in West Covina you live in
Riverside you live in Montebello i'ma
tell you right now man
don't do those comedy shows in that area
go over there to the Comedy Store and do
shows like in Hollywood you know the
valley you know shows were are far
enough for you to think about what the
[ __ ] you're doing I know you can't do a
show in Montebello and you live in
[ __ ] Montebello cuz you never know
how bad you sucked and you're gonna go
home work be home in ten minutes
you gotta go like doing show in North
Hollywood where's I'm Jose Ortiz where
the guy named Ortiz I don't know Ortiz
other job you go along here with a
Chavez yeah see Jose Chavez here the
show in the valley so you go do his show
you know you go do his show and then
when you drive back to the back to the
valley you're back home you realize okay
this is gonna take a while I mean you
know what you did wrong
we got terremoto ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen let him know he just came back
from Mexico alright cuz they wouldn't
book me when the Mexico [ __ ] up Mexico
you know it the only natural disaster
that cannot be predict
know what a man can tell you which other
muscle coming ladies and gentlemen know
we have local by only by coincidence
God coincidence there were DC's
southeast they see you right there
my brother a legend in the game I've
been told a legend that please put your
hands together for the one the only
earthquake earthquake but whatever
laughing everybody walk Philippe but you
know gonna have earthquake after that
Mexican earthquake and you have Mexican
podcast yeah yeah well you know I just
wanted to let him know I'm with them
down yeah the first time we run into a
earthquake with on a Southworth airline
we're sitting right next to each other
wasn't it was there man he want to give
you autograph tiny Lester o1 are tiny
made all that money feeling yeah can't
get his [ __ ] I fish Tony I said it to
come to my club and just scare people I
know but you were telling me like look
at look at Taliesin over there was blaze
all out feet all [ __ ] up yeah his leg
was all in the middle of Iowa we go
dinosaur foot I look like he walked here
close was awful they were sandal better
nerdish oh I didn't know he was trying
escaping his tippy toes he's supposed to
take Hermitage socks you should take
shower socks porcelain is allergic to
his feet
come on come on tiny all this money you
make can we get a pumice rock can you
please soak your feet your toes damn
chain make it black people look bad type
of person need boots all your life and
when you go to the beach you were still
here there however he was too dressed in
his feet and Rose GOI don't you mess
with me
- couldn't get your autograph he said
having anybody speaking to you could
have robbed you of my boy you know now
also man another time I was so happy
when I got to here you want um Howard
Stern man yes I said man yeah just done
your special yeah and my friend my wife
Lisa she does she look wise man she's
right there that's sure why yeah she's a
fan of ours man and then how much turkey
came in one week a good man to some
house term bro I was uh I can't really
do a house turn but it doesn't even
sound like Howard sir anyway a Monday it
had you in a Monday and yeah yeah I just
finished his awesome special plated he
played a clip where he was then I what
listen to me that's earthquake yeah oh
you been how you been sleeping Howard
yeah he don't hang around a hood that
much yeah man but thank God he was in
say he was laying in his bed and he
turned on HBO and there I was and he put
me on and it was pretty cool and then I
saw her I saw I'm earth-quaking clerks
and then he was and wait a minute man
earthquake just wrote his own lines
those part of your bits you said that uh
you were waiting in line you have mescal
back there my fool be ready already
yeah and then they say get a fool back
and I say why cuz they races I said you
can't taste racism that cheeseburger was
not racism black people gotta let it go
you gotta go
gotta let it go sometime I had to eat
that cheeseburger so how you been Wanda
Smith how you been early with all this
clap what the climate right now was
Trump in office hey man I've been good I
mean just like the first white man had
been the supervisors in my life no black
was shocked like all of a sudden he just
came I always knew Trump exist that's
the white man I knew I don't know these
other ones they talk about that's the
white man I know and it's not just as
pigmentation as his mentality it's a man
that's not qualified for anything but
feel he knows everything I mean just
because you're a businessman don't make
you a great president matter of fact we
went in hiring a businessman we were
looking for a president
but that's where it comes and you know
I'm glad he became president because
that shows what happened when you own
vote and you ain't vote so you got what
you deserve
had you voted we wouldn't have had and
we was about seventy thousand votes
shorts in three states I do that info
states when they come see me out of all
my fans they moved him in them three
states we would add a different
president Hillary gonna write a book
what happened
I would this will happen [ __ ] laws you
[ __ ] up in sent us and got this
[ __ ] he was used the only person
he could it be period
Hillary cuz why America's not ready for
a woman president at the end of the day
just not wait just nutty
huh women weren't even ready yeah women
hated on her more than anything oh hell
you would learn when the first woman all
of them were galvanized and go vote from
there like [ __ ] please I mean I'm not
her if not her who she was the most
qualified candidate ever she was the
first lady so that means she know how it
is to be the woman to the man eight
years yeah eight years hey that's like
when you help me when you're going for a
job and this is person qualified I
caught [ __ ] yeah other dumb
[ __ ] but he knew some notch on
how to do her do the job but he knew
somebody yeah this girl we don't want to
correct you that's how it goes dog hey
man see a white woman go down like that
it was rough but you know or crying bro
oh yeah don't I don't know what he cries
I don't got presidents problems I'm
serious president ain't never laid me
off I don't have president prior guys
see the councilman problem there prom
why would you put on or probably laying
low I see the cops but why would you put
sweeping day on Wednesday so I gotta
move my car knowing Tuesday night is
Taco Tuesday night and I hanging gets
wrong of course i'ma leave my car there
past eight o'clock in the morning you
bastard sweet clean on the day I'm gonna
be there like Sunday when I'm on the
road oh man I have used your line
several times when people ask me about
politics I mean if somebody was asking
you about immigration Mexicans and you
let your like a key there that's true
killed me man you said I don't care what
they do man I got my apartment just get
your partner let them come on in have
you ever been up up in North Dakota it's
a lot of room up there [ __ ] we got room
is my Caucasian friend
they got to pick on somebody you gotta
build a dam wall ain't nobody putting
that wall up man
take too long in homeboy said he's not
he's he's gonna leave some places where
there's gonna be a fence so what
happened that [ __ ]
hey man listen let them all sneak over
here they lucky to have Mexico as our
neighbor it could be like China with a
[ __ ] that hates you on the other
side you got good workers all the time
this with this country's build on I tell
people all the time
slavery was not about them feeling they
were superior they just needed somebody
to build this [ __ ] country while he
was fighting Indians oh yeah that's it
I see productivity you see what I mean
productivity the white man is in too
slow how you make and he can't because
he I'll fight in you I know my history
hell yeah
I know what's going on how they say in
the ghetto now I'm woke even waiting
next to a Mexican he all work your ass
yeah brother look ridiculous yeah y'all
made him up I go to college I work with
a Mexican he put up a roof in 30 minutes
I had to get out the truck and say take
a break Senor what you rest for we can
pay by the hour not about a roof racing
take a break call your family check on
your neighborhood take a break don't you
take a piss enough
y'all have no job description y'all do
everything can you trim that tree was up
in the tree I like get your ass down we
ruthless I know man every time so nice
to work day laborer yeah I get hired you
do one thing and then like the owner of
how I should do other [ __ ] don't even
got nothing to do the construction did
you watch my kids while I'm gone lady I
put this roof right here yeah because
y'all were cleaner they let my black ass
go and hide another Mexican that's true
about that man cuz I have a friend named
Ronald page cocoa rest in peace every
time him and I will go look for a job
they would like call me back and not him
and he was like believe me man he was a
very smart man he was smarter than me
more educated every job we went they'll
call him call me back and not him back
no ask him man how come didn't call you
back
you were more qualified all cuz I'm
black and he [ __ ] here I'm a
they're afraid I'm I started Union and
started a more money and benefits with
the [ __ ] not he thought he was
gonna take extra breaks but brothers
always more vocal like that mom our
nation's capital is cotton money the
whole goddamn country is cotton money
that's how strong you imagine what you
could do if you had somebody else do all
the work for you just sit around and
just think of good [ __ ] that's what
slavery was allow them to sit on their
ass and have us do all the manual labor
then call your lazy and then have the
audacity that called me lazy
oh yeah I ain't late ain't lazy I tell
them all the time but I ain't leaving
this country because I went to Africa
I like whoo I don't know who these black
people are but they can say oh my ticket
ain't coming back over here and it
already broke me I'm already house made
how did you feel when you saw like the
same type of people but you have
different feelings I know when I go to
Mexico and I'm walking around I see my
cousin's man they're like oh really am I
gonna [ __ ] that chicken you know they're
not gonna make that chicken fight that
rat you know
maybe we'll go to a dog fight I'm like
I'm Mexican but not like this but Don
Africans they really don't like
african-americans no yeah they look at
us like we made it
[Laughter]
you could have been in bondage your
grandmother day now they didn't catch
your grandmother grandma I didn't yeah
they do have a problem with us
yeah I'd had a choice so we went really
quick on the road right infraspinatus
ojos the radio show ya que BLX I do a
time to time with the world my gebbs -
yeah yeah I did - my Capshaw
cuz ya'll was that uh total Andale
a man you marry what's going on good see
you got your wife in here you know these
thoughts are coming out happen to Kevin
why in the hell did he make this damn
video man do you think who hold on let
me just say this and I hope you get back
to my boy because I'm calling them here
you taking my car who in the hell told
you to make that video second of all you
cannot be extorted unless you have
something of value in a video or
whatever of me with another woman is no
value you can't you you can show it to
whoever the hell you want I would never
ever ever ever ever confess to something
like that ever
I just don't understand it I just don't
get it man I don't get I'm trying to
find my boy and say what the hell was he
thinking
you've been a story for a million
dollars ten million but listen I'm sorry
listen listen steel you're missing the
point
tell us sir how can you be extorted if
you don't have nothing of value scenario
I have a table of meaning
you and I'm gonna tell and show it [ __ ]
go ahead
sure do whoever you want you or two I
want to mean you know anger you ten
Alice no what no what nothing thank you
cuz supposedly like you're kidding you
can barely tell it's him in the veil
ring give a [ __ ] if I was there with my
social security card my ID passport my
son right beside me me saying my whole
name with a tattoo I ain't got say
that's my mother for me it's crunch oh
yeah yeah I would [ __ ] that ain't no way
hoe people told him to get on his
Instagram with 35 million people why did
they do that I don't know man
do you think maybe because nothing's
cracking right now let's throw something
out like No so what's up with that I
don't know - wha Matthew is the dumbest
[ __ ] ever that's what I'm saying
it's that I don't get it you validated
the thought right you validate it you
gave her a platform you authenticate it
whatever any sense you have allowed
other people to ask you questions about
that the only person you supposed to
been talking to was your wife your wife
go and tell I made a mistake you you at
first you don't own led to no public you
listen I was not put on this earth to
live up to your expectations of my life
you have a problem whatever I do did not
show problem you were entitled to that
opinion but you're not incited - yo fact
see there was never any of that on top
of anything wasn't enough
no if that's to be you said he would sit
there and got they blackmailed him and
he had to give it up if that's blackmail
I get blackmail every weekend or was it
just a beat TMZ at the punch you can't
beat TMZ they're gonna know what you did
was authenticate they couldn't show it
right because they don't have no
copyright you can't just put that on it
will always be at the bottom and who
showing up you got enough money that you
can squash it even anywhere you don't
want brung it to the mainstream you
don't want to put it on that platform
and now's the regime PS node it is the
reason he did it it's a kid because
extortions against Allah to get that
chick in trouble with the law
why the [ __ ] you care to get her in
trouble just don't [ __ ] with her no more
you don't want let getting her in
trouble yeah oh stop it's gonna be
greedy woman's all day life right right
opportunities all I like it ain't gonna
discourage you you know only way you're
gonna discourage that is do not
participate in the [ __ ] [ __ ]
the long period it's nothing to you sit
there you win the business you allow Joe
people to sit here and talk to you to
tell you this is what you need to do to
hold up to this image of you being a
happy husband and all that's the only
thing I think right oh it's something
more than that
yes I was going to partner to a
sleepover yeah you drop a statement now
worse here nothing Wow 140 pots don't
cremate your ass right Daria yeah what
now you got the girl out here and hired
a lawyer she done did a public
[ __ ] statement today press
conferences here to tell you I'm not no
stripper
I am i recording artist well an actress
and I need somebody to protect I didn't
extort anybody and I didn't do anything
illegal
exactly Kevin you ain't do nothin
illegal morally wrong okay
illegal no [ __ ] you make it a
statement phone never in anybody listen
to me now
you on this level never ever ever allow
another person to be on your level you
do not validate them do not step down do
not give them a platform to be on the on
the hard-working you have did for your
career
you never do to allow them to talk
whatever they want but you never stand
on the same stage we didn't invalidate
the accusation [ __ ] them [ __ ] what they
think [ __ ] what they think let them do
whatever they got to do but to to never
even answer
ma'am I ignore game is outstanding so
we're never know
no one's gonna rip up all the
earthquakes sex tape well if you do that
[ __ ] gonna be in seven
different listen I will [ __ ] that long
you got a four-minute taper it's gonna
be seven different shades of sheets on
that muffler they don't say why does she
keep changing cuz that was seven
different times
cuz that that quit I don't sis it if you
ever there with a thought why are you
there that long anyway I don't want you
up there you're posed to be sitting
there hugging it then you're coming in
for your own press your own selfish
reason I'm not here to satisfy you I
know I'm a type of man anyway my manhood
is not licked
or linked with my physical or sexual
performance I don't feel bad if you're
gonna quit thank you very much about
here yes hotel room so quick they've
rented the room back check that I'll do
a new purse don't ya you got just to see
this next we pop out and boom you saw I
didn't I wasn't even there I only like
room don't even get a shot that quick
not even Tyson confessed huh then even
Tyson come nobody do it and he could
have nobody especially when you're
talking about infidelity with you you
only did to your wife and your God in
your family you don't owe your public
debt now what Eddie Murphy said brother
never
a line is eyes I saw you with me Eddie
wrote that shits were years ago it
wasn't me super big kind of situation at
that before no because I don't lie I
don't when I was married I didn't cheat
and when I'm dating and I'm into
somebody whatever to agree of our
relationship it is what it is but I
don't I don't get caught it never had my
windows bust out never had no women run
up against an Argand this is business we
always had an understanding exactly what
it is so I never get in court in that
point because I I don't play those type
of games I always got cheating both
girls go to my house see dirty bastard
I'm shooting live why my mother talked I
was like worried you guys could've gave
me a ride home - I'm gonna told me my
mother told me a long time a woman can
deal with anything longer she know what
she's staying and I learned that some
[ __ ] can't staff or difference
in certain pairs can you just establish
a wig yet which our relationship is you
take it from there and at the end of the
day you looking for yes so know you'll
find somebody to believe I got a friend
dear a got two wives
yeah [ __ ] huh I'm talking about
C D right Drive ha - uh-oh
both from they get along and everything
I had him on my fur on my arm my
father's days show and he had both of
them come out there and I like god damn
and he walked all in but I respect them
and I respect their understanding
because they cool ain't no snicker
you're grown up if you need to again I
don't have that sexual appetite to [ __ ]
with two three women
cuz that's why I'll do an RJ - ah
because if I got two chicks in the bed
why don't man gonna be satisfied I know
man
so I gonna be disappointed you Ray has
two assistants in huh - assisting they
work for him or the dental girls who do
you radio them his women oh no you know
Hollywood that
that's it he goes straight with it man
they're young millenniums they own a
whole nother level they it's sitting out
there in the whole night but now they're
my his women where's your two women I
just need one dog you say when a girl
ain't got it like that dude good I just
need one a lick and stick girlfriend for
my girlfriend yeah your wife look your
wife any planner might be looking for a
divorce attorney I won't be saying that
right now with a woman with a phone you
find it real quick opening up and
closing OMC I need all the chair that's
the word say when you break with your
wife she's the worst
she's doing stand-up now oh thank you
never been busted cheating you don't
cheat right I never been busted cheating
ever know Rajee go no no I don't do that
[ __ ] I mean I mean there's no reason
even I mean even she is a she ain't if
she is then I don't I don't need extra
if she ain't then what we talking about
yeah
pseudo saying to get in that that have
that narrative you have to go in that
situation and say okay it's me and you
and whatever the parameters of the
relationship you start from there and if
they change then I'm the first one to
tell you they changed cuz I don't want
some kind of problems I just don't want
that I just just sitting it just the
most embarrassing thing is to have some
woman sitting here I had the right first
I'm not that type of person had the
right to tell me when I done wrong to
you and then I'm sold
say no earthquake on the if you're in
the runway and the red carpet was
cameras on you and you your girlfriend
right here
mm-hm our they walked up to you so
earthquake what Kevin Hart what happened
I'll say he [ __ ] around on his wife
and made a stupid area statement next
question and I was walking the red
carpet on during the Emmys
I never HBO special and this was the
answer they told me to give ask me so
what happened with Kevin Hart Phillippe
it's all I think what Kevin Hart did
right now it was the right thing to do
right now for his family and I think
every heart needs all the privacy right
now to work this out [ __ ] man got into a
demanding got him can't do that answer
that's me okay what's the answer
what's the answer you told him being
there done that okay I could [ __ ] no but
I wouldn't know I don't know all right
let's go there I would never confess on
Instagram oh hell no that's my life it's
for my private life you know you let the
whole were like earthquake said you're
letting the whole world in in your
business not yet not only that you give
them the right to question you about it
leverage yeah I mean he was that went
out to eat with his wife and TMZ was
there it says good Kevin that y'all
working it out and everything say thank
you man Kevin gone with it you eat what
did you have did you have a taste of
humble pie you just and you know Kevin
small so you can't you can't even timid
a torch eating cake well yeah see that's
the kind of shot yeah you can do shots
you're gonna get those shots you'll be
going you're gonna be the mean you're
gonna be there is nothing that justify
making that move you know to mean
career-wise whatever somebody gave him
some bad advice in my humble view the
publicist some circle huh I don't know
he that video thought was done late
right we've seen a Saturday huh we seen
the Saturday remember
yeah whoever his publicist is
this was no long scandals no Olivia Pope
because that was terrible but Jumanji is
coming out too though there you go
but ok and let's see that doesn't matter
because this hurts them even more in my
humble opinion Kevin stand up his
content is funny but he's never been an
overpowering comedian his appeal has
been he's personable you like him he's
likable he's non-threatening you like
him now you [ __ ] with your likability
of your brain yeah especially with the
number one consumer of brands women so
that don't help
it's just don't [ __ ] help the last
thing you want to do is tell women you
out this month I'm [ __ ] around how do
you been broadcasted all alone you'd
have found your real but she the best
thing ever happened [ __ ] [ __ ] around
on his shoddy body round with it with me
I can't call my [ __ ] maryam no mo the
rip is gone what kind of mistake
let me go back to she's the angel
[Laughter]
solidify you probably all you're
treating just like your vans [ __ ] the
game up my rib yeah
that's biblical you say you'd have met
your ribbon anything
she went here if I'm going back to my I
wasn't going back to the career hey my
friend going back to the crib with that
bad chess move bad bad bad chess move in
my humble opinion bad chess move if you
ever see me on that [ __ ]
apologize it's a pistol to my head
[Laughter]
[ __ ] pistol the holy my god
underneath my nuts my books they say I'm
so sorry everything y'all seen is true
say it yes I slept with that [ __ ] she
was in the area and I had to polka
yes yes that's what I did she was down
this wrong the first night yes it was so
how'd you get started in comedy and DC
or where New York no I was in the
military for nine years soldier yeah in
the war broke out so I told her the boat
will raise a fight yeah I told him I own
mine practicing for war but y'all
fighting for real so it's time for me to
get the [ __ ] on out and that was a first
goal for ya the first one they was
fighting overall and I didn't even
strong yeah yeah I'll say man you bet
cynics are the bad woman like chemical
Wars and yeah man and I loaded nuclear
weapons for you drop one yeah I drop a
new there they were let go or the blow
that they came over that word Broken
Arrow yeah that's when he's got the new
missile they call the president yeah
that's pretty [ __ ] up yeah yeah trying
to get to a 2 Live Crew concert man you
have to put it in a b-52 and I didn't
father the problems of seizures off the
checklist because I was in a hurry to
get there to see them holes and and the
fits didn't go and hit the ground
everybody ran I said you same boat you
can't outrun no nukes so I just sat down
and smoke a cigarette and wait for the
police car man no really nuclear weapons
nuclear bombs are more safety safe safer
than conventional bombs because there's
so many different mechanics and
mechanisms you have to do for it to
unite to get off but everybody else
didn't know that the [ __ ] just
scattered bow like roaches when the
light came and I just sat there like
damn I ain't gonna get to see my hos
tonight did you make eating make it to
the concert no cuz I at that time the
base commander come they shut all the
way down they call the Pentagon say we
have a Broken Arrow what'd you do wake
the president up then they have to sit
there and then they rush all of us you
know they'd have to debrief us and then
they'd take us to the Hart's I mean to
the hospital to draw blood and
everything to see what we under any kind
of drugs or
call and he drove my blood and all they
found in that [ __ ] was incompetence I
just took you off the [ __ ]
plane to put me in a snack bar you just
pass out all the [ __ ] snacks -
almost got em in the commissary but I
ain't give a [ __ ] that's what crackers
I'm a real G that's one good thing about
the military they know they fight
communism they practice it because if
you were a five you get the same money
as ephod as loading bombs as an ephod
that's serving [ __ ] doughnuts
so I don't need to be out there long as
you [ __ ] that [ __ ]
so I was an e5 serving Donuts coffee and
serving [ __ ] and that's how food
Rucker miss it
Oh Bom bro so they woke up the first
Bush then huh yeah they welkins ass up
somewhere my name is in the [ __ ]
Pentagon I'm telling you make it him
made history that name earthquake no no
man it was a Nathaniel Martin Stroman
sergeant strowman rap about [ __ ] and it
was like this [ __ ] dropped it
and it was so funny about it you know
the CIA and Homeland Security kept
coming to see me I like what the [ __ ]
aroma true he said every time we go into
Iraq and into a kada and horrible and we
go into the caves [ __ ]
we see a picture of you let's say what
the [ __ ] he said maybe if they said this
is who we want to be he dropped a bomb
in America we tried to inspire to be
like him I said [ __ ] mine was
from being illiterate and just between
incompetent [ __ ] I wouldn't
personally try to go with you told him
the truth got no affiliation with him oh
come on but I dropped a nuke on the
United States and they thought I was
part of the group my religious reason
you understand I like poor chopping
white women there's no way I could be on
that side I had to tell them not man
part of no goddamn I Chi to kill myself
like man can't be no we can't be no
terrorists you got to be on time with a
bomb
you understand they have right there try
to get a black man to kill you just put
your black matching up your terrorist or
a Mexican man and you at the airport and
you doing about ticket not gonna use my
miles below we need you to kill yourself
today go to straight to voicemail
Oh your first big show you did
earthquake ooh
live jam or before that I did Def Jam I
did I did all the shows Def Jam coming
for you
but the biggest show from a confidence
standpoint to help out more than
anything was when I met LeBron
everything Lonzo moistening always had
his fundraiser down in Miami when he was
playing with him and American Airlines
Arena I was like 19,000 and everybody
this and this one cat was cat Highness
[ __ ] out oh yeah we met cat when
it was cat in a hat
yeah yeah which I have a room in
Montebello we paid 50 bucks and we used
to book Katt Williams kid it was called
calico cat in a hat
he's to wear a trench coat with a hat
yeah yeah cat a very intelligent problem
people don't know that he from the same
town at least a date in Dayton Ohio he
from Dayton yeah [ __ ] snitched on me
from Dave when I was in the military
[ __ ] told I stole ammo for the
camera to wanna Matthew a Kodak no man
was back in the day snitched on me I was
in Okinawa Japan every time somebody say
date and I remember trying to find see
didn't the [ __ ] still alive
and what happened at that big-ass show
oh okay well happy was cat was high he
was I mean he was hot just with cat
after the movie yeah that's the first
time his first time have a poor [ __ ]
yeah when he was I mean
phenomenon and
sitting in the green run y'all know
there's comedians sitting in the green
one and I had to close the show because
he had to leave early for whatever thing
off of it he said I come but I got to
going on anyway we sitting back in the
in the green room chillin and everything
me Steve Harvey Steve is hosting it and
you got all the you know the known
groupies in their green room you got the
ball players y'all gonna see some finest
women in your where in the life just go
anywhere some [ __ ] that bouncing ball
throw ball catch a ball some about balls
these holes come to it
so anything you smell [ __ ] the bat
kid he's fine ass [ __ ] I love this [ __ ]
and we in there and you know you can't
relax cuz you ain't been on stage yet
everybody else is cool but you ain't
been we in then all of a sudden you hear
17,000 I don't know what this
[ __ ] saying but she's so strong
it's coming underneath the door like the
fall well I got damn and they got the
monitors up
so you know Steve like turn the [ __ ] on
and he turned it on ha this
[ __ ] gonna kill it and that's a
comedian what we used to say oh he's
pissing all along the stage ain't
nowhere safe to walk you're gonna slip
in the closing part about it had Dewayne
Wade in the front and you remember back
in the day when the rainway had all his
agility and everything he used to fall
all on the ground when he when he shot
man can't mimic that [ __ ] all the way
through Oh
19,000 [ __ ] just holler standing
no gone so these hosts are saying well
this y'all overweight ain't nobody going
after that either close by Steve Harvey
was my man that's why he's there my [ __ ]
you talk about I got a [ __ ]
going behind this [ __ ] right now gonna
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] you talk about it did
the [ __ ] you know what you taught my
mood [ __ ] out the way say hi good thank
you
I guess he threw his fog handlebars had
to yeah man and to not have no credits
other than my talent go behind that mug
of course I did yes you I never hurt you
could just it's like we sitting here
right here it was coming underneath the
door and you could just
it was penetrating to the point you're
like what the [ __ ] did this so that's my
most memorable most accomplished part of
my career part of able to sustain that
and take it to another level with
nothing credits of a recognition of an
in my talent fog was that deep was so
foolish that I addressed today today's
arm indoors Murr are today's add ISM zip
recruiter are you are you hiring do you
know where to post your job to find the
best candidates how zip recruiter is
different with zip recruiter you can
post your job to a hundred-plus job
sites with just one click
then powerful technology efficient
efficiently it matches the right people
to your job better than anyone else
zip recruiter you were looking for a job
through zip recruiter no but I was not
heard about a job agency zip is it when
your needs it because the zip is quick
no juggling emails to call your office
simply screen rate and manage candidates
all in one place with zip recruiter
easy-to-use dashboard that's tough man
remember just going into a job row and
getting hired just walking any hired
they don't do that no more hot you can
walk in and get a job at that nomura
he'll tell you to ply on the Internet
like I remember I'll be knocking on
doors may easily do one to sweep I'll do
it
no yeah man how much one give me two
five bucks a week c22
I would like
and one day yeah I'm looking for your
brother worse was some fool car to
action find out today with zip recruiter
has been used by businesses of all sizes
to find the most qualified job
candidates with immediate results and
right now my listener can post jobs on
zip recruiter for free and that's right
free just go to zip recruiter comm slash
fool
that's sip recruiter dot-com /foo one
more time try it for free go to zip
recruiter dot-com slash full zip
recruiter you got it bro
Yemen you you zip recruiter I will now
all right who you honno-ji weather slash
honest you know he did an exterminator
on the side so you need to purchase the
rats spiders I wrote for the last money
returning money being variable that's
great you were done games where you
could have find the promoter to pay you
know cuz I don't tell a joke without my
money in my hand since day one a
[ __ ] one you never did like
open mic well I open mic I didn't look
to get paid but if we had an agreement
no no joke II no money cuz he it just
didn't make sense to me I'm all ready to
give you my product and then hope you
know we have give me my money and then
we ask I'm in one time when you said it
happened messing with my agent and they
said they pose a pain and he posed a
payday and what's a person that we did
because certain I'm promoters you know
they have you didn't work with him a few
times and okay my [ __ ] had my money so
I went to his office me chocolate and
rest of we just took all his equipment
and got in the limo and went to the
airport and he called me by the time my
flight to go but before that's before
the Kings of Comedy you were touring
with them towards you yeah I was talking
with uh differently each one of them
yeah yeah no you were in the show
but in the beginning before they thought
of documentary no um I never I never was
part of the King of Comedy of being on
it that was uh Joe
I mean guy and the rest of them I just
individually told which each one of them
before the DL Steve of course and seeing
it we have done shows together and me
and Bernie has never worked together
wonderful Bernie Mac Gail no more
[ __ ] problem no muffled from told me
the best advice gave me some great
advice when I was shooting my my pilot
you said don't be afraid to fail yeah he
was sick during that time on the CBS lot
he was carrying around this thing and
now I know what he meant in other words
don't worry about it for fail just do
your best and let it stay where it is
because you know when you get a shot
you're trying to be perfect and
listening to that [ __ ] being
nice to this person [ __ ] all them put
your vision now put it down put it out
in the universe and pray on it and let
it do its best so you had a pilot deal
and all that out man on ahead whoo I
don't know eight developing news was so
I just had one and I'm feeling bad it
didn't get picked up I had eight eight
bro so you had one every year for a
while yeah what's that like we kept the
money the problem with that and it's
different for the one that I'm doing now
another one yeah I'm doing it now um is
once you pitch your story you sell the
story
then they pop they parting you up with a
writer that used to do this and that and
then they say yeah I get you I get you
and then they bring you back the script
you like nah ain't what it is and you
tweak it then you turning it over to the
studio and then the studio say well if
you just change this to this make your
brother a gay brother I really don't
have a game problem but if if I put the
gay brother I'll be very you know I have
some investment in it and I could see it
going father's like
your dream in front of you like I then
they put it to the next part of studio
to the network then the network said
well maybe you had a white cousin cuz
but if you put a white cousin on the I
think we could really do it okay put the
white coats on there and then by the
time all them put their hands in it they
put it in there your concept of your
show there's nothing which you imagine
it's supposed to be in the beginning and
then when it fails first thing they tell
you is Quakers the [ __ ] ain't
goddamn development deals in ain't none
I'm coming to fruition when they don't
tell you is none of them [ __ ]
was what I originally had when I sold
you the [ __ ] that was no apology it
said in his pitch yeah they pretty much
has just changed it up yeah change it
all up they change it so this deal what
I did was I'm just gonna bring you the
finished product
this is my vision right here
I'd only you you you you you you you you
none of this soda to you you love it
imma bring it to you already in you
don't like it I'm going down the next
street but we will not have these
[ __ ] right here telling me who
should be in it here's the finished
product that's what Bernie Mac gonna say
don't be afraid to fail someone like
Paul Regan said what Paul Rodriguez had
a play right now called the pitch and
one thing he said was that listen man
when they get you the writer if you
complain they call your complain
exact you don't wanna be a troublemaker
then if you agree to it when it fails
they put it all on you exactly and
that's not even fair no it ain't a fair
game but you got to understand - it's
one other thing you don't it's your
dream don't ya man you close to being on
network television and you have a person
that's able to provide to say man I got
the perfect writer for you
hey bro listen to me they add
[ __ ] with the Bill Cosby is I'm
[ __ ] we're gonna build college this
the [ __ ] that worked on this
show and they sitting it you noticed my
[ __ ] don't got you but he has you know
you go this [ __ ] ain't got he
just looked at your tape last night
understand I'll show you you turn your
[ __ ] awesome see that [ __ ]
get out the office he needs to get the
[ __ ] out the office for real get him out
but you're sitting in you then picked up
to 250,000 you already spit that [ __ ] so
you like I [ __ ] I'm trying to get
home you're not a man so you sitting
with that [ __ ] like I so you go to
dinner with this [ __ ] you fly
them all way I don't flew my father's
all way home to DC so they could be here
the surrounding them my family to keep
the concept and I got it I got it
you get that [ __ ] like man saying it so
now you're back in here right and again
this is what it is now you get the
problem Paulson now you're difficult are
you gonna beat this dog are you gonna be
the writer see you can't be polled you
can't be both you can't be both because
you can't write it in star on it at the
same time listen [ __ ] this is my
life so you have to talk to and you're
just sitting there then you become
difficult but that's a fear to fail you
allow them to go I was afraid to fail by
allowing that [ __ ] to go look
through it crazy [ __ ] like don't tell
your leg away man how about your
neighbor with a vampire yeah you need a
neighbor that's a vampire werewolf yeah
you're on what about a talking dog or a
pair yeah I got no talking dog and no
ghetto you know this is that why I'm
saying told him jobs in that bridge like
just see how buddy that ghetto blaster
speak to you give knowledge exactly you
can't be telling you this late at night
and your dead father talks to you yeah
yeah in the middle and that's when you
go man have young kid show goddamn
starbug coffee drinking ass up my
[ __ ] face ah oh and the initial and
the initial wall with a blank paper
ready write down your ideas but they
don't never use none of them learn are
you going to that big meeting the same
person they already said I saw your [ __ ]
you're hilarious the other person who
said I just started [ __ ] you're
hilarious
was there bar shows up those
[ __ ] are not laughing at
anything to the boss
laughs oh forgot how funny you were now
ah and they sit around a bit and table
read choir to forget about like as they
did other other ass-kicking they did and
they wait for the boss to laugh yeah
yeah yeah
hmm I say I don't think the [ __ ] funny
even this [ __ ] I'm serious man
I remember be at a show and they wrote
all my jokes for me right and then I
they got mad cuz i complain i say like
all right I'm just gonna ask one
question how many times can I say up
there I didn't write this [ __ ] oh that's
funny and they got they got mad but
there wasn't gonna be right more jokes
yeah you have to take it but they got
hurt but you know what something you
gonna hurt people not because you have
the alright is there ever be labeled
difficult then not to allow somebody
else to play with my opportunity or
dictate my opportunity so labor whether
the [ __ ] you wanna lay difficult hard to
deal with whatever but at the end of the
day you're gonna find another goddamn
job as a writer am I gonna find another
shot to get on goddamn TV for a sitcom
and this is my deal ain't chores I had
had the margaritas all the time who
[ __ ] deal is it I think I know I was
getting a call we're not gonna fire your
writers like hoes huh hey man I'm just
trying to get on and see getting on now
if I just feel strongly showing it with
my vision how it is did it enough
knowing what it is I could I could I
could I could live with that I can live
with that but I can't live with the
other way of the process and I wasn't
going that way I can't go that way and I
don't see how no with all due respect
and I don't want to say it in a negative
way I think that even happened to my
good friend Marlon have you watched this
show no watch it
I saw a pilot yeah
yeah yeah it brought that in that that's
the first thing there brother so late in
the season huh in the summer so that
means that a better worker is gone yeah
and I watch it because I support with
all due respect anything that's black
meat or black man on that mom phone for
30 minutes just as a dot hell yeah
and I'm DVR and they're playing it all
the way through I'm just saying I'm just
saying I don't [ __ ] what it is if it's
black I'm on it meet you if it makes
again it's a car chase put eternal fire
they're chasing Pepe yeah you got to man
you I support Vera wash don't I yeah I
noticed that nobody had ever said
anything bad about you that I know of
it's always been positive maybe I'm
hanging all the wrong people now you
hang with it even Tommy T and people say
that to me all the time like quick you
don't count all the people on the thing
off of it you don't you don't care all
the people and everything and I just
have one simple enough I'm already
underpaid so extra $200 ain't gonna
change my [ __ ] life I'm already
under pay its [ __ ] out here
making a quarter of a million and a
million dollars and night telling jokes
why ain't better than me so I could give
a [ __ ] about an extra 20 or $200 or $300
in the club concurred on that point I'm
underpaid cuz if it's a comedian I hear
getting two to four to five million
dollars a night
[ __ ] I care I'm gonna get I'm making
twenty five thousand go forty thousand
on fifty that I'm making and I opposing
maybe fifty two give me my 50 and I need
to keep on concentrating I get this
goddamn 5 million kid no time to be
arguing the club memo club owner over
know two hundred [ __ ] dollars nickel
and diming and [ __ ] on I'm already
underpaid if fifty thousand is the limit
then [ __ ] then I'm gonna sit
there and get look for all fifty but if
it's five million being me [ __ ] I care
about the
fit so no I don't go in there with a
click oh yes I get 95 85 percent of the
doing the rest of it sit down there I
can look and tell how much it is plus or
minus with my eyes but no I don't have
nobody clicking and this and that on it
you don't have no comps to come in my
show and I can look from the stage how
many seats are available just all visual
and I knew my numbers I go you might get
two or three months luck is in on me for
[ __ ] two the game had a two to three
sneaky lights in the side minutes and
around about an ice box TV show I can
[ __ ] like an earthquake southerner show
right for example 5000 people don't show
up because of accidents or hurricane or
those pretty people are gonna show up
they resell it yes
and they don't give him his cut no
that's a trick that yeah we can't even
complain about it's like a known fact we
have to accept it yes they buy the
tickets and don't come
we just gotta cut off cars and they
resell the tickets and I won't even go
get that keep the honey box sitting at
they keep the hundred percent now and
give it to me and we could play we're
difficult yeah we'll see I have a
different mentality
goddamnit I'm trying not to [ __ ] with
you no mom I wanna [ __ ] with the
mistress where's the main [ __ ] no time
to be talking to decide decide which man
just do what we doing told you I'm quick
with this a minute I'm kidding I'm gone
no emotions no it don't care about that
man
understand I'm gonna eat your food I'm
gonna do my jokes I'm gonna pick up my
check and we work for that weekend and
I'll see you next year that's when you
do it brother I understand how so
comedians when I go have dinner with the
owner play golf I don't want to go hang
out with you if I twist my ankle came to
the show yes my girl I just did a show
with her in El Paso was that Chingo
Bling
no it was a theater oh oh oh no it was a
nice
stare down and true the Abril Chavez
theater yeah man I remember doing that
show man yeah 40 people whoa it was sad
and they were all scattered it's tougher
than a big room huh
that man we did well though I got there
so I got him Otto did you see the wall
[ __ ] no there's a wall right there
that's like I'm not going to see the
wall just like I'm not going to outer
tries to see a jail my [ __ ] [ __ ] I need
to see [ __ ] around slip and push me
out this vision no [ __ ] you and whoa I'm
in San Francisco want to go see Alcatraz
[ __ ] I want to visit a jail [ __ ] [ __ ]
out my face man drop me off game shows
coming up
yes Friday I know Saturday I am in
Detroit I am at the Fox please come see
me I got to do a cruise for the Jazz
capital Jazz with Earl Klugh that's all
next week
I'm going on tour you will see me or you
can hit me on instagram at the real
earthquake and you'll catch all my dates
I'm gonna be there and I think I got a
couple more months shows I just forgot
about i'ma being Houston with one of the
chicks that didn't make it to Destiny's
Child with the money yeah that's the
first girl she's opening up the show so
I open up the show and I close I say boy
I know she really got a feel real bad
[Music]
with your ex [ __ ] she hit the lottery
quake SOUTHCOM right quakes house.com
you can get me on they're all instagram
at the real earthquake and uh real
earthquake on twitter to come out and
show to write every week yo show um I be
on um no I don't have a show uh uh yeah
I'm on the show call in the cut
you don't bounce yes or bounce TV as a
black television
Station so please call your local
provider and say you want some black
people in your life
bounce TV yeah movies coming up no don't
have no move I did a couple of movies
man but I forgot the name of them cuz
the check ain't cleared yet so I don't
like the problem until the check clear
so you do this yes congratulations
yeah so this time oh yeah oh I think so
I mean I'm we're good we're gonna mean
we shooting it this time
oh yeah yes and I'm shooting it and I'ma
turn it over to them I'm doing it myself
what I'm doing is they funded it in ion
been bit lee-evans
which is the producer that produced
Jamie Foxx show Martin Lawrence and he
has to show that I'm on in the cut and
he has like for the TV shows on on
balance TV we're collaborating right now
to do my show and with the we write in
the script now a lot of fact I'm gonna
get to that today and we don't have it
already shot and shoot it and then sell
it and then God's will you'll see me in
New York in May at the upfronts was so
full of joy the question for mr.
earthquake no man we cover it all man
thank you very much man
badass dude man on the road my dog Lord
Yu's that's what you know oh man you are
the man I Love You Man I love you more
but no I remember what they were in the
airport
and then I didn't even have to ask I
sent someone to your show for you yes
yeah that guy wasn't in the Italian guy
yes which one the one of them the Tempe
improv yeah yes and this is Louie the 13
that that stuff that Snoop Dogg smokes
you know you could smell how strong it
is one of the best thing I had my before
I get up out of here I had my own radio
show in New York WBLS
afternoon drive quake house quick yes
yeah I thought about putting your name
on a marijuana brand and getting paid
and cutting of the crepe the quake cush
or the earthquakes of teba I was
thinking about it does that be got kids
man I never mind I [ __ ] around my son
smoking my Kush I can't discipline hope
you enjoy that man oh I'm gonna try as
soon as I get out there all right but
that was one of my highlights am i ready
I got the smoke whit snoop at the job at
the station was good I'd ma'am thank
y'all for happen thank you very much
everybody who showed up Felipe worldcom
I'll be in Houston this week half of the
proceeds will go to the food back in
Houston and improv Rescue yes improv I
saw you on there I live in Houston so
Ryan yeah and um follow me on instagram
at the real earthquake and we're good
thank you very much man I love you
brother
all right like you Louie the 13 shining
yeah